us to do what first Timothy chapter 2
says to do many of you may have seen
that there was a call to - particularly
on this Sunday pray for our president we
don't want to do that just on this
Sunday we want to do that continually
day in and day out so I want to ask us
to bow our heads together now and pray
for our president well God we praise you
as one universal king over all you are
our leader and our Lord and we worship
you there's one God and one Savior and
it's you and your name is Jesus and we
exalt you Jesus and we know we need your
mercy we need your grace we need your
help we need your wisdom in our country
and so we stand right now on behalf of
our president and we pray for your grace
and your mercy and your wisdom upon him
god we pray that he would know how much
you love him
so much that you sent Jesus to die for
his sins our sins so we pray that he
would look to you and he would trust in
you that he would lean on you that he
would govern and make decisions and ways
that are good for justice and good for
righteousness and good for equity every
good path Lord we pray we pray that you
would give him all the grace he needs to
govern in ways that we just saw in first
Timothy chapter 2 that lead to peaceful
and quiet lives
godly and dignified in every way god we
pray for your blessing in that way upon
his family we pray that you give them
strength you can't pray that you would
give them clarity wisdom wisdom the fear
of the Lord is the beginning of wisdom
fools despise wisdom and instruction
please o God give him wisdom and help
him to lead our country alongside other
leaders we pray today for leaders in
Congress afraid for leaders in courts I
pray for leaders at national and state
levels please o God to help us to look
to you help us to trust in your word
help us to seek your wisdom and live in
ways that reflect your love and your
grace your righteousness and your
justice we pray for your blessings on
our president toward that in
and Jesus name we pray amen
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
tell you what
it's not how necessarily planned on
ending the service today